good
machines
hello everyone so I have a last name you
can call me manolis for Simplicity I
graduate from Columbia University under
the supervision of michale
and I am here under 4G Fellowship
uh so today typically I I prefer in need
of the fellows to speak about smooth
analysis and Beyond what case analysis
that it was the area of my thesis but
today I will try to narrate a little bit
the story that I worked a lot during the
previous years so my academic
interesting on one slide everything
mathematically interesting my academic
interest in more details uh I do lots of
stuff like from Beyond watch case
analysis Game Theory Quantum I love
complexity tfnp stuff in the mail I have
tried a little bit to incorporate the
optimization dynamical systems and in
general what is happening with the
equilibrium computation in different
models
I'm not doing it yet
same with lower balls but yeah so today
we'll try to speak about a like a vision
that I had like creating some theory of
optimization about real world problems
and let's start by looking back to see a
little bit the hit so we can a little
bit agree that this is more or less one
of the most fundamental problems that we
want to tackle like find the minimizer
of an objective function typically the
function is non-convex in some cases if
we are not in the combinatory
optimization problem we have some
lipsiness some derivative to take we
will use the evaluation in the grad in
order and we hope that we can do
something if the function is convex we
can find the minimum otherwise problem
can be really hard
on the other hand
even if the problem is hard we have
enough Theory until now that says that
okay even if they cannot find the global
minimum the local minimum of the problem
uh could suffices for my could be
sufficient for my case because typically
in the majority of the machine learning
problems we have non-furious
local Minima so more or less all of them
they have a similar value they're not
like that
um and we have analyzed very nicely the
first order grade in this end that was
my first paper in my PhD career it was
about the zero order model of that but
to be honest like is that really so easy
the optimization practice and the answer
is no first of all because what we want
to optimize probably it is in different
positions sometimes we have to protect
some of the models of the position of
the X variable that we want to optimize
and sometimes what we want to optimize
it does not belong just to one server
just one agent and that brought more or
less the rise of multi-agent learning
what I want to say is that like you know
20 years ago we were trying something
that was referred more to a single agent
optimization in a very static
environment in comparison with what
happened in today in practice like in my
opinion like game machine optimizations
in optimization appear everywhere like
from the markets and the players that
they want to like
they have their own incentives and
they're trying to find out their best
outcome for them to biology like team AI
games right now with Robo soccer and all
that fascinating stuff and other times
we have game machine optimization with
an implicit way like we want to create a
robustification of our model we want to
create a
um and a a defense and adversarial
attack
so just with new questions new solution
concept game more or less there are some
equilibria in some notion of a game and
together with new Solutions came new
problems like in the past we were trying
just to find the local minimum and the
issue is let's hope that we will not
find the saddle point nowadays there are
multiple different hazards that you can
that you have to tackle but okay one
step at a time so the first question
that I I think in optimization and Game
Theory we try to tackle was the case of
two players the the min max case uh
phenomenon said that without solving
that problem we cannot solve everything
and more or less when the problem is
convex concave when we have two players
that they want to maximize uh their
utility or minimize their loss and some
of them is equal zero then we can do it
nice okay uh
but the question is like is there any
broad family of non-convex problems that
we can solve them using some standard
optimization Dynamics
uh okay I can give like just for a joke
and answer yes we can do like a
classical change that was one approach
that computer science and optimization
had let's relax a little bit but the
idea remains that we are in Congress
concave spaces and then it came in my
mind the following observation
if you look the ppad completeness for
example for min max non-convex non
concave optimization the landscape is
horrible but you will never see that the
optimization landscape in practice in
practice what is happening is something
a little bit different for example let's
take guns that was one of the main ideas
that re-initiate the mean Max
optimization
um there is something like a hidden
structure the problem is non-convex not
concave but the reason is a little bit
different
that that is from a tutorial of good
fellow who said look it's fine all these
problems that I see in the examples
about the convergence to the equilibrium
of a model but in practice the players
what they are doing is the following
they're represented as deep models deep
neural Nets they are updating in a
parameter space in a different space
than the solution space uh where we
don't have any convexity
so that comment came in my mind and I
started working on that idea that I call
it the hidden games so let me explain it
just by the example my question is the
following let's assume that we want to
play a game that typically is solvable
but let's say that the solution set the
the the the strategy space is so large
that we cannot really choose so what we
are doing as a policy making we are
using some neural net and we are
parameterizing a lower dimensional space
and we're trying to find some parameters
that is the the only thing that we can
optimize the parameters of the neural
net and the neural net give us an advice
and tell us place this strategy so in
that kind of situation you have a zero
sum game for example here a rock paper
scissor but the problem is non-comics no
concave why because the only thing that
you can control is the parameter of the
neural Nets and that creates in my mind
the idea of hidden games so the whole
idea is that you have like a convex
structure but you cannot control
directly the the parameters of your
study see the only thing that you can
let's assume that you have
for mathematics now let's assume that
you have like a neural net that is
smooth like a smooth relu okay this is
the only thing that you have and you
have the parameters of the model that
this is the only thing that you can
optimize so and the other thing is like
typically it is not a neural net is not
invertible to find out the solution with
like find out the solution in the convex
problem and let's find out the
parameters so the good news with that
problems is that okay we know what is
the solution the solution is like the
solution of the hidden game of the
convection cave the question is how on
the earth we can find the set on field
and like the first thing that we are
doing typically in the Middle East
gradient descent so in the first thing
that we proved actually was that all the
cases of different guns can be modeled
on under this framework and after that
there are also other applications like
in biology uh let me just say it one
more time the idea is that I have like a
bunch of players they are controlling
some parameters the parameters are
feeding in
some smooth function let's say that it
is a neural net and then we have the
losses and the players are trying to
optimize their loss
uh okay and now the first thing that we
analyzed was the hidden by linear game
and where you instead of like having X
transpose UI you have that thing and
what we prove is that either you will
have cycling phenomena it is very
impressive that we can prove that like
this is what we call pancare currents or
you will have some spirit equilibria and
some very specific diverting phenomena
then we started taking what is happening
if you have hidden strictly convex
concave case in some models we saw that
there is something like that as a
phenomenon of convergence so I become
stubborn and I say okay let's find a in
the general case if again I can create
probably
um I I if you see a less hard problem so
I can create difficult tasks but in
which cases I could find a method that
will give me an AC equilibrium uh so
first of all I want to say that like in
a paper that we had we tried all the
famous style stuff like creating descent
optimistic grading extra grading
optimistic multiplicative weight updates
and we find games that all of these
cases are playing
uh and then we create a method recently
that we call Hidden GBA so the whole
idea can work about any hidden
monitoring game so this is a different
kind of generalization of mountain games
if you go to the optimization landscape
they see the mountain games and then
they say ah let's make it a little bit
less into accuracy of the inequalities
here what I say is I want to solve the
monotone game but I don't control the X
parameters I control only the Theta
parameters and the x is my neural net
let's assume that it is smooth what I
can do and the the solution that we gave
was like a method that we call
precondition Hidden grading method uh
more or less is like a new understanding
of what we call Natural gradient and the
main theorem that we gave and I like the
intuition that we got from that was the
following that look
um
as long as you have bounded the singular
values in the Jacobian of your hidden
model
then this preconditioner natural
gradient method can find the natural
cream so it's a here is a non-convex
landscape but I can find the equilibrium
so why I like that a lot because because
of that remark like the whole idea is
that the neural Nets work nicely because
they are really expressive with a small
number of parameters they can achieve to
span the whole uh the whole landscape of
the optimization so the fact that you
have a positive singular value which
means that you have not lost rank in
your representation
now closing my story uh having that in
the pocket what I would like right now
to understand are
other interesting questions like first
of all this is likely the neural the
natural gradient method as I understand
it from my perspective it is like a
method that it is centralized so the
question is can we do that with an
uncoupled Dynamics
can we parallelize it better can we
create private methods that they they
will be secure for every player the
other interesting question is like can I
take like some neural net uh improve
like the smooth and with some smooth
analysis with some average analysis
displaying that this is a claim that
there are multiple male empirical papers
that they say that but can we create a
mathematical model that shows with
smooth complexity that the rank is good
the conditional number of the neural
Nets are good what are the application
of that because the whole idea here is
that you are trying to do some policy
making uh so the question that I have is
what are the application in econometrics
in conversation games and in RL and just
as a last question
like what is the complexity of a hidden
game like is it PPD complete is it CLS
complete or something between thank you
very much
[Applause]
back to the definition of a hidden game
yeah yeah of course
yeah here up here we are so each player
has a loss function the loss function
depends on the choices on the strategies
that the players submit so we have n
players every player submits some
strategy so this is the classical
utility that I have but I don't control
the
uh the he won the chi one Cayenne I
control all in the parameters that will
give some outcome so these are not
convex functions yeah yeah so the the
exercise can be smooth otherwise the
problem is like a composition of complex
things that they give a convex there
yeah
yeah and like
even though they have you here
um one smooth complex the question is
like can you show somehow that the um
in general the Jacobian of models that
we see in practice
has good conditional number so for this
model you want to prove that this is
Jacobian as well yeah yeah yeah but
because that would permit the for the
method that we have uh to have good
convergence guarantees for today at the
local Optimum at the no that is even
more amazing at the nas equilibrium at
the exactly
uh yes
is there a condition on the on the
uh on the actual game that tells you
when is it a hidden game no no that is
amazing question okay so let me repeat
the question uh I will phrase it with
the very TCS perspective is there an
algorithm that I will give you a game
and you can find out if it is hidden or
not I'm not sure probably it would be
able to complete or even something more
than this but this is an interesting
question this is a very interesting
question
that's why I said
like
besides the definition I don't know like
a but it would be interesting to find
like a process that looks mathematical
formula for example and
find out the if it is yes or no
great well thanks
thank you very much
[Applause]
okay